pas pour l'europe l'est républicain la
parole est à monsieur philippe le ray
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre depuis plus
de deux ans nous vous interpellons
régulièrement sur la situation
catastrophique des agriculteurs un pan
entier de notre économie s'écroule en
juin dernier vous étiez engagé à
soutenir nos éleveurs leur situation n'a
jamais été aussi catastrophique
ils ne connaissent toujours pas
concrètement votre plan d'urgence en
attendant nous sommes en train
d'examiner le projet de loi de finances
rectificative et deux sujets nous
interpelle premièrement la ponction de
255 millions d'euros sur les ressources
du fonds national de gestion des risques
en agriculture qui aident les
agriculteurs en cas d'aléas
cette ponction s'effectue au détriment
des agriculteurs
ce fonds affiche une bonne gestion et
vous le sanctionner c'est incroyable
deuxièmement la création d'une taxe de
5% sur les abattoirs dont le chiffre
d'affaires dépasse 250 millions d'euros
qui financerait un fonds de soutien aux
éleveurs qui lui n'existe pas et n'ai
pas créé on croit rêver
cette nouvelle taxe risque de fragiliser
les filières de l'élevage en mettant en
péril les entreprises du secteur dont
les marges sont extrêmement faibles
cette nouvelle taxe risque également
d'aggraver la crise que traverse
l'ensemble de cette filière
ce sont des milliers d'emplois qui sont
directement ou indirectement menacé
particulièrement en bretagne
vous comprenez bien que prendre de
l'argent sur un fond destiné aux
agriculteurs ou créer une nouvelle taxe
ne font qu'empirer la situation
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
allez vous vous opposez à ces deux
mesures extrêmement dangereuse je vous
remercie
merci monsieur leurrer
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt porte-parole du gouvernement
ce président est monsieur le député vous
avez évoqué deux sujets premier sur le
plan de soutien à l'élevage qui avait
été présenté par le premier ministre à
la fois fin juin et ensuite le 3
septembre suite à la manifestation qui
avait lieu à paris
ce plan est mis en oeuvre ses 180
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
pour diminuer les cotisations sociales
et mais ça c'est 155 millions d'euros
qui sont d'ores et déjà mobilisés pour
diminuer les charges qui pèsent sur les
exploitations agricoles et ses 46
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
aussi en plus pour aller vers
l'aménagement et les années blanches qui
ont été demandés par les agriculteurs en
termes d'endettement
ça c'est le premier point 23 mille
dossiers ont été étudiés dans tous les
départements
et d'ici la fin de l'année c'est plus de
dix mille dossiers qui seront payés et
en plus en particulier monsieur le
député ça vous concerne pour les
élevages porcins le deuxième point vous
avez évoqué cette taxe réserve at war ça
n'a jamais été une proposition du
gouvernement et nous sommes défavorables
à cette taxe pour que les choses soient
claires ensuite vous avez parlé du fonds
national de garantie pour le fn gras qui
gère les cales habiter se font
effectivement a aujourd'hui fait environ
abordés autour des 300 millions d'euros
300 millions d'euros qui depuis que nous
sommes en responsabilité et même avant
sollicite en moyenne par an de mobiliser
entre 50 30 50 ou 60 millions d'euros à
chaque fois qu'il était nécessaire de
traiter un aléa climatique
les fonds ont été mobilisés mais ce que
payent les agriculteurs sur leur
assurance va au delà des besoins annuels
donc la proposition est simple c'est de
faire en sorte que les agriculteurs
payent moins cher sur les assurances et
réadapté se font aux besoins qui sont ce
que l'on constate de manière régulière
tous les ans et je le dis au delà de
cette question
l'état assume à chaque fois sa
responsabilité face aux calamités
agricoles
donc au delà de ce qui est la recette de
ce fonds l'état finance à chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire les
et calamités agricoles merci monsieur le
ministre pour le groupe union des débats